all right all right all right now Sundra
we just got back from redstorm
entertainments we played a bunch of
Division two and you're gonna be honest
I'm starting to see history repeat
itself from when destiny two was
struggling around cursive Osiris and
everybody jumped ship on the really good
Division one point eight batch the
original game actually had a really
rather spectacular like post-launch like
life added a lot of new content it
refined like the leveling system in
particular and also the dark zone
content in addition to adding sort of a
quasi Battle Royale style mode called
the survival mode judging from what we
played you know it they're very much
trying to keep that second wind that
they got during the post-launch period
and the developers were keenly aware of
like a I guess the positivity and they
got from the feet from the fans it was
interesting to see how that all came
together with the next games expanded
take on the familiar dark zone a
multiplayer content which is a sort of
this very unorthodox PvP ve gameplay
which of course means player versus
player versus environment alright so
here's what we're gonna do we're gonna
start with a deep dive into the dark
zone specifically now there are three
dark zones will dedicate most of our
piece to that and then towards the end
of this we'll get into a dedicated PvP
called conflict weapon balancing and
then we'll get into some of the things
we we don't like quite as much about the
game like movement
oh yeah haha
alright so the dark zones the first
divisions dark zone wasn't that great at
launch it got better over time a lot of
the issues focused around just the power
disparity of high-level rogue players
just absolutely smoking low-level
players and for a lot of people it just
wasn't fun it just wasn't a place that
you would go unless you had a high-level
crew and it was this huge section of the
map that was just dead to you
essentially which was not great division
twos doing a lot of things to try and
make that better
friendlier give you more many styles
more inviting and uh one of the things
they're actually doing is that they're
having players sort of take part in a
set of introductory missions for each of
the three dark zones and one of the
things that the developers wanted to do
was that they wanted to sort of allow
like even like the the more casual
players to you know feel like you know
they can take part in the dark zones
because as you said earlier it was a
very hardcore environment oh no no what
are some of the more specific changes
they're making to the dark zones the big
thing is that the Luke Ryan is a bit
different this time one of the things
that you could find in the dark zone in
the original division was that uh
there's like these sort of infected
items and uh that's still there but you
can actually find normal loot like you
know within the dark zones in the
division - and you know that's a pretty
big change yeah that's a major change
and uh you know by making normal loot
like us more easily or readily available
for players you're actually you know
you're you're feeling more rewarded I
guess you know for actually taking part
in it however there is still infected
items and those items are a lot more
rare and you know they're I guess
they're more valuable than like you know
standard drop so the I'm assuming like
you know these infected items will be
like more epic level items and another
thing is that you know they're bringing
back these or loot chests but that would
a bit of a twist this time these loot
chests have like specific dark zone keys
and if you have the key you can unlock
the chest however if you don't you can
choose to basically pick the lock and
you know just force your way into it but
if you do that then you're gonna go
rogue and that's also another big change
that you know
we're seeing with the dark zone is that
they sort of I guess basically
overhauled the rogue system yeah they're
done a lot of changes to it now and now
there's a lot more ways that you can go
rogue it took us a while to wrap her
head around it we were there for a
couple of hours and and I feel like we
kind of got it by the end yeah but
there's a lot of different approaches to
going broke in the dark zone and there's
a there's a large number of there's a
spectrum of rogue so light rogue is
things like picking chess killing a
player and stealing their loot cutting
something off of a loot line that can go
all the way up to manhunt where then
you've kind of snowballed into killing a
bunch of other players however there now
escapes they all can do for manhunt
other than just wait out the timer so
you can wait out the timer for manhunt
but you can also now find a manhunt
escape node that you hack to get out and
then there's a whole other aspect of
rogue where with these chests you can go
rogue picking a chest and then you get a
series of other chests to go pick and
you get more rogue as you pick further
and further chests and that actually
leads to you escaping to a special
underground vendor know who you can
level up to buy extra cool stuff hmm
so one really cool impact of that for
solo players is you can actually have a
full rogue run now without ever firing a
shot yeah you can just stay away from
other players and they've made changes
to the map just to make you more aware
of where other players are yeah so if
you want to do a stealth run it's easier
to stay away from danger if you take
part in more rogue activities you're
basically going to become more notorious
and in that specific dark zone and
they'll that will make you more of an
enticing target for other players now I
will say the rogue system felt a little
bit too protective in the build of the
game that we saw right
it could change before the final build
but there were a lot of ways to go rogue
and when you were looking at other
players it was hard to tell if there
were somebody who you could shoot for
example you could potentially have rogue
players being hunted by non rogue
players and because shooting players
doesn't make you go rogue you have to
declare yourself rogue it was confusing
which was which so you could shoot one
of them and do damage and you could
shoot the other one and do no damage but
you also would not go rogue unless you
declare yourself rogue by holding down a
button
it was definitely confusing considering
how I guess sort of involved the systems
are and again it's very nebulous in
terms of like you know how you become
rogue and you know how you stay like
sort of neutral actually the one case
that you know really stuck out to me was
when we were doing like a set of rogue
missions lose us in a party then we got
to a point where he found this terminal
on a wall and we knew like another team
was chasing behind us so we ran up to
that terminal to basically cash in and
turn in the reward then that basically
ended our sort of rogue run but after
immediately after that another the other
team like basically caught up to us and
they started shooting us but they
weren't doing any damage because we
basically disengaged from being rogue
and you know it was it was incredibly
awkward seeing that because we were just
basically standing there while they're
basically unloading like you know their
heavy machine guns into us and like
nothing was happening and it was like
and that's and at the same time we were
like wondering what's happening like are
we still rogue and it's like no we're
not we're we already turned in to reward
so I do think that's something that
definitely needs to be I guess tinkered
with a bit because it's it's definitely
especially you know from playing the
first game that you know and seeing how
the dark zone works in that which is in
itself has already went through a number
of changes to become you know sort of a
you know easier for people to get into I
do feel like some parts of the systems
need to be sort of cleared up a bit you
know and made a lot more clear for
people we had another great moment to
where we were about to extract and we
saw team setting up on us and we had a
more classic rogue moment where we just
press the button and went rogue on them
preemptively and it worked out in our
favor oh yeah it was great
when it works it's really it's a lot of
fun
okay so let's talk about guns division
definitely has the kind of ammo of
sexual nature of customizing your
weapons and boy does it feel good
to just mess around with those guns yeah
a customized and you know basically you
can just rip apart an entire weapon like
you can add underbarrel attachment slike
grips neo silencers and you know other
modifications like you know what have
you and what is interesting for this
time around is that you know they're
adding another layer of customization
with the specialization classes so which
only comes in towards towards the end of
the game like after the campaign
actually I think they said full 40 hours
yeah the the full the mechanical full
campaign is supposed to supposedly
according to the developers it's 40
hours so at the very end I'm assuming
after the last mission you'll be able to
picks a particular like heavy weapon
like a grenade launcher crossbow or a
believe an anti-tank sniper rifle and
that also comes into play with how you
choose to like you know sort of deck out
your characters like you know particular
gadgets and like you know what sort of
modifiers you want to put on your
weapons but also for the gadgets as well
so you can you can make some really
interesting like you know characters and
again I can't show you the menus because
the restrictions but gear sets are much
bigger this time around I'm collecting
armor sets that give you different
resistances bonuses damage output get
them yep oh good flank oh I shot you in
the ass with a crossbow you still there
you think he's behind you he's down a
nice is clearing that was good good
stuff guys the division 2 has standalone
PvP as well in addition to the dark
zones
it's called conflict and it feels like
the Wild West when it comes to how
effective guns are even though there's
stats balancing there's definitely
builds that are better than other builds
we definitely had much better luck with
some of the classic guns that do well
like a vector and some of the light
machine guns definitely needed heavy
modification to become viable in PvP
also one guy was like you know
just wrecking us with like this auto
shotgun which you know I feel like maybe
need some balancing but it'll be
interesting to see how the I guess this
more traditional PvP mode will sort of
play out once it once it you know
releases it launched that is compelling
in these types of games to get wrecked
by something and try and figure out what
it is you know how you get it or how you
beat it by making something better and I
would say my biggest takeaway from
playing the PvP conflict mode was that
you still have a lot of control over
your ability to make a great PvP
character we played about two of the
maps I believe and honestly I was I was
sort of like getting tired tired of them
you know like after the third match sure
so but yeah they're the only three pvp
maps at launch so they would definitely
need some more now the game does have a
pretty extensive post-launch sort of
schedule so it does seem like they'll be
supporting like in addition to the dark
zone but also the complex modes as well
okay so one area I'd like to talk about
is just movement in general oh yeah and
we did ask in a developer interview fair
or not why there isn't a crouch still in
this game and they said that basically
they wanted you to engage but their
cover system and that was the extent of
that answer but I had so many specific
examples in particularly in conflict
mode where I was behind a barricade and
I was having a hard time getting my
character to push up and over a
barricade to fire at an enemy player who
was unable to fully take cover behind
the sloping hood of a car because the
hood slopes and the sticky cover system
doesn't really give you very good
options in terms of how to hide parts of
your body that are just that determined
to be sticking out at any given time
yeah there's always like a little bit of
yourself sort of peeking out like your
head or let your shoulder or whatever
and I definitely did some work with a
sniper rifle on parts of people's bodies
that I don't think they intended to
stick out and trying to inch backwards
when your snap to cover is kind of
awkward too because your character tends
to rotate at a certain point I would
still like a Crouch button in division
and I would like more fine control over
the cover mechanics
all right so Division 2 is coming out in
March so is Destiny's season of The
Drifter and anthem will have already
been out February 22nd so it's a
competitive market and early next year
overall I like division a lot Division 2
feels like a very solid sequel and I'm
looking forward to I don't know to be
honest I'm looking forward to taking a
break from destiny and playing it I
think a lot of people were trying to
find different options for destiny at
this point how are you feeling about
that launch window is that it's going to
be crazy competitive because I think
there's so many different like games
trying to sort of take that destinies
crown so to speak anthem is basically
the closest to game day destiny besides
destiny and the division actually
already has like a very dedicated
following and a lot of people are
already looking forward to this game and
I think this game is you know is looking
very promising if a bit familiar to the
first game it feels very similar like
you know to the first game but um I do
think a lot of the changes to the dark
zone in particular and I'm also the
expanded and a PvP should you know
really I guess give a lot of the
hardcore players something to really
look forward to well we'd like to hear
your thoughts out there or if you have
any burning questions we can get answer
for you put them in the comments below
for more coverage of division 2 we're
certainly going to be playing a bunch
stay tuned to game spot calm is the kind
of team unity we need good teamwork